okay everyone this is my spoiler review
of the highly anticipated Barbie this
was directed by Greta Gerwig and written
by Greta Gerwig and Noah bomback when I
saw the teaser trailer for Barbie and I
saw it was referencing 2001 A Space
Odyssey that gave me so much confidence
about how good this film could possibly
be besides the fact that Greta Gerwig
was behind it because I'm a huge fan of
Greta Garrick as well especially
ladybird and I'm a huge fan of Space
Odyssey so I was happy to see in this
film that wasn't just made for a trailer
that was actually in the film the space
odyssey sequence and I think that's so
important because this film takes a lot
of inspiration from that film and the
themes of that film and what that film
means to me is it's a feeling you have
right there's a part of A Space Odyssey
if you haven't seen it go see it
especially if you like Barbie but that
it's about us as humans being imperfect
and that's okay and I still got that in
Barbie by the end that's what I took a
lot the biggest session that touched me
from this film was that and it makes
sense that space odyssey is referenced
in this film it makes sense how it's
showing you those little girls went from
the dolls that were babies to Barbie and
Barbie is the mysterious figure that
comes to them and changes them and I
love how she used the same themes music
from space odyssey when Ken goes to the
real world and he is now being
influenced by the patriarchy how men
behave in the real world he's lost his
innocence at this moment and what makes
the writing so good of Greta Gerwig she
follows a great key with writing with
characters that Barbie starts the film
as a Barbie doll clearly she's happy all
the time everything's perfect she's
perfect but by the end of the film she's
transformed into a human and and you see
that Ken is going on a little bit of a
different Journey where like I had said
he also starts as a Ken doll but he
loses his innocence when he comes to the
real world and becomes basically a worse
version of Ken and by the end he
actually changes and he learns and he
actually learns from Barbie and there's
this great line when Barbie says you
have to work on yourself and not be
about who you're with and what you do
and having that self-worth of saying
that good liar she wrote It's Ken not
it's Barbie and Ken I thought was really
really good but what I love about that
is that the whole film to me is about
blending that theme with themes about
feminism and that we also as humans but
in particular in this story with the
woman in the story that they have to
also stop being hard on themselves and
other women and people in general and
societies stop having these high
expectations of women that they're
already put themselves with other people
put on them and that's shown through the
speech that America for era's character
does that by the way in a full theater
got collapsed from the whole theater I
have not experienced that in a film in a
long time so again that's just how
effective this movie was to people and
their emotions and what they're feeling
and how it's working and it's earned but
because Greta go away as a writer with
Noah bombach knows so well how to start
a character's journey and follow that
Golden Rule that really works like that
they at least change by the end that
happens with Ken and it happens with
Barbie in this film so that to me is
already such a win in the sense of
writing for a movie like this and what
made me a little nervous about going
into Barbie was that it was Greta
gerwick doing a big product right and
what I love about this film that I can't
remember in recent time was this good at
not selling out and making it still feel
like a Greta Gerwig film sure it has a
big brand on it but I don't feel like
she ever lost herself or anything that
felt like okay that was a sell toys that
was not what this is is about this is a
Greta Gerwig film with just a little
Barbie wrapping on it which I thought
was great now that goes also to the
casting which was excellent because
Margot Robbie is the perfect Barbie and
I mean you watch Ryan Gosling as Ken
you're just thinking the whole time like
could there have been a better Ken I
don't think it's possible and he really
goes like a hundred fifty percent in
this film and him breaking out in song I
did not expect I thought he was great I
thought Margot Robbie was great and
Margot Robbie still is one of the best
at acting with her face she's graded it
and speaking of Margot Robbie and the
humor in this film my favorite moment of
this film was actually The Meta humor
that goes throughout this movie but one
of the best standout moments was Helen
Mirren as the narrator when she says it
was miscast as I'm saying the Cassie was
great but it's a miscast to have Margot
Robbie as someone who isn't feeling
beautiful I thought that was really
probably got the hardest laugh in the
theater I thought was the funniest
moment of the film and that's a props
too that no one bound back and Greta
Gerwig do such a good job of blending
humor and knowing when to change the
beat and make it serious and not feel
forced I feel like the whole thing
flowed really well and you're only gonna
have humor go up and be more effective
just having Will Ferrell on the screen
playing the CEO of Mattel to feed into
the metahumor of Mattel who creates
Barbie which I thought was great but
anytime I see Will Ferrell and anything
he makes me laugh so again I think he
just kills it in little moments too like
him trying to jump over the cubicle for
some reason when they were going after
Barbie was great and of course the
production design the costumes off the
wall and you really feel like you're in
this Barbie Toyland and it never breaks
those feelings of a Barbie movie somehow
too in a Greta gerwick film which is
very impressive and it stays by the
rules and you see that really well done
when they have this can battle between
all these cans and it's still all these
goofy toys but I'm still feeling very
into it and series at this moment in the
film because there's a lot of powerful
messages being given to you but you're
still laughing you're still like this is
also ridiculous we are in a Barbie
playset right now with Barbie toys
fighting and I did like the twists a lot
that the mom was the one who actually
was connected to Barbie and not the
daughter and also that it was connecting
to her as a mother and that those
memories playing with that doll with her
daughter and how Greta go work
beautifully Blended that again into
themes of expectations of women how
they're supposed to be so I thought that
was really clever writing and when you
go to that last scene which I thought
was so powerful and that's a lot props
to Ray Perlman who played the creator of
Barbie Ruth Handler she has a moment
with Barbie when Barbie's fully
transforming now after all the faults
she's seen in humans and becoming a
human human and she's seeing all these
moments as a Barbie toy through Barbie's
eyes but is now processing the human
emotions and taking them in and how they
feel Joy how they feel sadness and that
it's embracing Humanity in that way and
that it reminds me so much of 2001 Space
odyssey's final scenes and hitting that
theme home again about imperfection of
humans and that's what we all are and
deal with and that's okay it's
acceptance of it so I think to me the
film spoke a lot about that so I was
really impressed at how much she pulled
it off your Greta Gerwig and I'm
praising this film a lot I really love
this film and I already had sky high
expectations you had all this promotion
with Margot Robbie dressing as all the
Barbie so you're thinking oh this is
almost dooming itself because everything
happened before it was going really well
but I think it lived up to that hype the
only two things I would say as much as I
love that final scene of Ruth Handler
and Barbie together I do think the music
that came in was a little too
heavy-handed and cheesy and kind of
ruined the moment a bit for me but not
enough that it like ruined the scene but
that's something that was something that
stood out to me I didn't like and maybe
I don't know I just thought Kate
McKinnon who I'm a fan of wasn't great
here and I feel like there could have
been more put into that performance than
what she was giving and I know she has
to play it a little more reserved
because she is a doll but
all right I thought maybe miscast or
again that just seemed like that was the
role you get where you can really
improvise and do what you want with it
and I feel like she was very
conservative on it too conservative so
those are the two things that I wasn't
crazy about but otherwise I really
thought this film was great so I'm going
to give it a 9.1 I'm very curious what
you guys thought about this film I'm
also curious if you saw this with your
daughter or the younger audience because
there was a lot of younger audience at
this film for me but it still felt like
a very adult movie a very heavy themes
and things that maybe would go over a
child's head so I'm curious if they're
just going to see this as a Barbie film
did they like it you know that's going
to be interesting because it's gonna
make a lot of money A lot of people are
going to see it so I think a lot of
people have different opinions on it and
that's good right but I for me as
someone who just wants artists to do
their best work always and if they bring
in a Big Brand like Barbie to still stay
true to themselves that's totally okay
and that's even more exciting to me if
we can get good at that right that it's
not always selling out or doing
something for a big company or more
money it's staying true to your art but
hey let's blend it with something people
recognize so people actually see it and
enjoy it I thought it succeeded in all
those ways and I really don't have much
bad to say about so let me know again
what you guys thought I'd love to hear
your thoughts I read every comment I try
to respond as many as I can please
subscribe it helps in so many ways you
have no idea and please follow me at
Steve Riley show on Twitter Instagram
and Tick Tock for more of me and I'll
see you next time